it has been a wild week for the failed
former president pictures of documents
in his toilet are published the fbi
raids his house he had to testify uh be
deposed by
the attorney general leticia james in
new york this morning at which we now
learn donald trump pleaded the fifth on
every question something he used to say
only the mob and guilty people did and
now there's an extraordinary new report
from rolling stone that donald trump is
desperately seeking
not companionship but a criminal defense
lawyer after that fbi raid inside
trump's frantic hunt for killer criminal
defense attorneys
behind closed doors this summer trump
and his advisors have been narrowing the
shortlist of criminal defense attorneys
he'd need to take on the justice
department the former president has had
preliminary conversations with tim
parletore a lawyer best known for
successfully representing an accused war
criminal about possible legal strategies
should the department of justice
escalate its probe or hit trump with
charges
trump's conversations with parliatore
and other newly retained attorneys are
part of his broader push to assemble yet
another new legal team both for current
legal woes and any future ones coming up
from the fbi and biden era department of
justice trump has been quizzing
confidants what do you think of specific
criminal defense attorneys throwing out
names big and obscure
in other words as one advisor describes
it
trump is conducting the apprentice avoid
federal prison edition
monday's fbi raid of mar-a-lago will
likely intensify that search
intensify that search
we are going to potentially see
uh a donald trump over the next couple
of weeks
that is unlike any that we have seen
before
now in terms of representing trump
there's this question of trump is known
for not paying his attorneys
so why would an attorney agree to work
for donald trump well there's two
different answers to that question one
even if they assume they're not going to
get paid because trump stiffs people
it might be worth it essentially pro
bono not deliberately pro bono but
essentially pro bono after the fact
for the notoriety of representing a
former president that would be one
answer the second part of it is that at
least for now
we still believe that the republican
national committee is paying donald
trump's legal bills remember that early
last week or late the week before i
mentioned to you that the rnc gave trump
an ultimatum
if you declare yourself a candidate for
2024
before the midterms we will stop paying
your legal bills
and it seems that the rnc has decided
both number one that it would be bad for
their midterm chances if donald trump
declares his candidacy too early and
number two
that they would rather pay his legal
bills than to have him be i guess not
represented by attorneys in many of the
different problems that he's having so
it's going to be a wild couple of weeks
people have been emailing me saying
what's the timeline on the next thing
like okay there's been a raid what's the
next thing when is the next thing we
don't know the answer to that but the
bad news for trump simply does not stop
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below